welcome to n54 news
the hell
[Music]
come on someone there
[Music]
uh excuse me
oh my bad kind of spaced out
welcome to the dewdrop inn where every
day begins with a smile
come on out [ __ ] anything available she
would notice
one second
oh yeah let's get one on the ground
floor is that okay
i'll take it look no hard
nova rum uh
suffocated looks like probably in his
sleep
a peaceful death at this town this guy
won the jackpot
gonna puke smell that right the
ventilation
vapor's from the room upstairs wait wait
is that
ah neoamphetamine
mean to tell me you can pin the exact
drug from just a whiff
like a police dog or what i'd say more
like a i want
a sommelier here kitty kitty
time to look upstairs got a feeling all
rippers supplies up there
somewhere close to a vent
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
do you hear me
[Music]
sophie the beta acid secure padressimo
and i'm putting you down for 10 bonus
points for solving the mystery of
booker's fate
it's clean work fee contracts closed
gratitudes are on the way